anyways yeah I would say feminists girls
that like are super only fans club like
that sort of thing and
um
whales number one is whales do you know
why they hate you like do you do you
because my perception like the way I
feel about it is that they hate you
because you're saying stuff there's
truth to it if there wasn't truth to
what you were saying they wouldn't hate
you they would just be like oh who cares
yeah there's truth to it and also it
makes them reflect on their own choices
so now if you're talking about how
female promiscuity is not empowering and
they've been promiscuous and they bought
the story that that was somehow
empowering they're listening to you and
they're like we gotta shut her up
see and here's the thing a lot of times
we have this narrative like oh they
bought the story when they're young I
don't really believe that I think deep
down on an innate level we all know
because what's the first thing that
girls call each other when we're mad
you're a hoe why are you saying that if
it's a good thing I feel like sometimes
that's a cop-out that women use well
they'll be like oh I bought it and I'm
like did you so you don't think that
women bought the story then why did they
do it if they didn't buy the story they
just wanted no consequences